foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored with
me Richard Tice and Isabelle oakshot yes
it's 2023 but is it really a happy New
Year after all Britain's face five days
of absolute misery in the most
disruptive rail strikes we've seen for
ages we'll go toe-to-toe with a former
Royal Union boss as there are warnings
the strikes could go for many many
months
and it's not just the trains that are in
chaos the NHS is in crisis with reports
that as many as 500 people a week are
dying because of delays in emergency
care so is it time to get in the army to
sort things out once and for all
I would like to get my father back I
would like to have my brother back
does it really mean it or is this just
yet another cynical massive money-making
exercise for Prince Harry at the expense
of his beloved family we'll debate that
later in the program
live from London this is here's Morgan
uncensored with Richard Tice and
Isabelle oakshot
and a very happy welcome to the first
Piers Morgan uncensored of 2023 with me
Richard Tice and Isabel oakshot taking
control this week whilst Piers finishes
his festive holidays and given the state
of the way the country is in we can
completely understand why it's not
exactly rushing back now a new year it's
about new starts surely drawing a line
under the bad stuff that happened last
year and hopefully feeling a bit
optimistic about what's to come New Hope
new ideas new determination to do things
that little bit better well that's the
theory my dream is that just as one of
the largest economies and one of the
most developed nations in the world
surely we should be well run properly
properly organized with low taxes great
Public Services things working reliably
and preferably on time surely that's not
too much to ask is it uh yeah hey it
feels like that is a pretty distant hope
right now now look I want to be
optimistic about 2023 and I'm sure we
are going to find some things to look
forward to but it really doesn't help
does it when the first stay back at work
is marred by yet another train strike
and we're already paying record levels
of taxes people are thinking about that
as self-assessment looms and for many of
us we're going to have to pay even more
come April and what exactly are we
getting in return for our hard-earned
cash and what exactly in Britain
actually works it seems to me that the
more we pay the worse a state public
services are in it's not just rail
strikes which affect the whole of the
rest of this week but also the national
highways officers are on strike this
week the people who run driving tests
are walking out the rural payments
agency is striking and next week some
ambulance workers are also joining in
the fun along with tube workers on the
Elizabeth line the London Elizabeth line
which only opened nine months ago not
much good if there's nobody there to run
it oh yeah and we've also got school
teachers in Scotland and nurses again
the week after and meanwhile the NHS
crisis just gets worse as record
pressure and delays in a e departments
record waiting times for ambulances a
cancer crisis all of this contributing
to a terrible excess death crisis
hundreds of people a week at the moment
the greatest increase in the 30 to 64
age bracket so not just the very elderly
but don't worry I mean at least our
borders are secure no one's entering the
country in record numbers
just imagine just imagine the outcry
that would be if nearly 46 000 illegal
migrants across the English Channel in
the last 12 months and if they were
being housed in nice hotels at vast
taxpayer expense yes that's you and I
frankly appears the only reason for you
to come back is to see your beloved
Arsenal possibly win the Premier League
for the first time in 19 years now look
I do keep telling you to stop being so
we're trying but it's not easy that is a
very very negative intro to the whole
thing I don't think people want to start
the new year listening to a giant whinge
Fest so we're going to try hard not to
do that have you got anything positive
actually I have have you noticed that
seems things do actually seem to work
when yes the military are running things
when they're running the logistics
passport controls seem to work rather
well just before Christmas when the
military were in charge the building of
the Nightingale hospitals the vaccine
rollout the Queen's extraordinary
funeral arrangements Split Second
perfect to name just a few so maybe
maybe we should get the military running
the NHS more on that a little bit later
but first another source of chaos is of
course our trains four in five Services
were canceled today as 40
000 rmt workers walked out and malls to
come with passengers expected to face
five days of misery this week but the
rmt boss yes Mick Lynch he said from a
picket line this morning that the
government know what they need to do to
reach a settlement
well we're outside again this morning in
pursuit of the settlement the government
and the companies have not put any fresh
proposals to us they know what needs to
be done to move towards a settlement how
to work through the problems and get to
some documentation that we could all
support but that's not happened so far
we're hoping in the next few days that
they will come to us and propose more
meetings and more sessions of
negotiations but at the moment that's
simply not there the government has let
these strikes go ahead and that's
unfortunate but that seems to be their
position at this time
well joining us now is former rmt
assistant general secretary Steve
Headley thanks for joining us today I
mean these strikes are going nowhere are
they don't seem to be making any
progress
well I mean look the the reality is uh
privatization has been an absolute
disaster and we're the worst of all
worlds now we have the government's
really uh getting the train operating
countries companies to manage the system
rather than actually run it the
government are interfering in the
negotiations in a negative way and uh it
really if you you did your sort of
neo-fascist resume of where the country
is bringing the Army
well yeah you brought me on to get my
opinion so there you go um and we we
have a situation where capitalism isn't
working we've got the NHS in crisis
because it's been on there yeah but
we're heads
let's talk about the rmt where the
medium pay of your members is about
about just under 40 000 about 38 000
pounds so quite significantly above how
much how much are you on
we're not on strike but nobody nobody
would notice if you did go on strike
would they well well
I'll tell you what would happen What
would happen if we went to strike is
that we'd be replaced and the point is
that the rmt members they're essentially
holding they're holding the whole
country to Ransom which I can't but oh
really you know I know you're reading
everything off your order Kudo because
you just standing for
they're the ones that are stopping the
negotiations the government are the ones
who are preventing the train operating
companies come to an agreement with the
rmt so they are holding the country Iran
so not the unions so where's your
original solution to this problem my
solution is to give people an inflation
pay raise that's not original sorry
that's not original you said that we had
nothing to original to say yes you asked
me a question
well let's let's have a complete change
of economic system what we have let's
have workers councils take control in
the country and see how your army get on
then that's communism no one wants
communism is that original enough no
one's communism in this country
realistic what we want is our public
services for which we're paying ever on
our taxes to work so we've got we've got
this sort of uh you know the the
variation of a British fascist party
rule out in front of us who want to
bring in the army
if you were listening you would have
heard that the context of the army
suggestion was the NHS although I have
to say I suspect that the Army would do
a better job of running the railways
than is being done right I suspect
Colonel blender could be a better job
than you know
let's try and be positive shall we Steve
as opposed to negative it is the new
year after all so you want an inflation
link pay increase what about the
productivity Improvement as opposed to
the old archaic Spanish working
practices that exists
work and practice well for example
um you have to sort of decide voluntary
working on Sundays for example
the property managers in Houston can't
do some Property Management maintenance
in Saint Pancras because it's too far to
walk they work for different companies
do something for ATV upstairs because
you don't work for them so you don't
want a different region so you just want
more more pay but with no productivity
improvements whatsoever that's not a
realistic world that everybody loves the
realistic world is you and your Mets who
you actually help uh you you come on
here as repeaters for have cut massive
uh tax breaks you're offshore and money
um
Steve you have no idea I'm talking about
I'm talking about foreign
all you want to do is you want more cash
for ever worse Services I think people
are happy to pay for proper decency
you understand right do you understand
that the money that the government are
paying the train it's actually getting
paid out to shareholders do you
understand that's where it's going I do
hundreds of members I understand that
and I've said I've said to your
colleague I've said to your colleague
I've spoken to Mitchell and I agreed
with you I agreed with you you shouldn't
be sending money the reality reality is
right that if that money wasn't paid out
the shareholders and it was paid out
that people had actually run the railway
as long as they run them properly
efficiently into a timely fashion like
happens in Switzerland all right let's
if that money was paid to the workers
instead of the shareholders there
wouldn't be a problem with that but
you've got to have modern contemporary
work in practices
like you've got that's right yeah we
work in the past doctor yeah and look
it's working out very well for you isn't
it well I'll tell you what we've seen
because no one's at work it is a private
sector in the railways have you not
understood that have you not understood
that the states
most of it's going into the pocket I
want to help you find a solution oh you
seem like it I do but you don't seem to
want to talk about productivity too well
that's some modern day practices one
that helps the industry no one else in
no one else in the UK has gas you know
when I can speak well I'm just asking
you the questions
foreign
you sat there and accused me of being an
advert for the Hitler Youth how do you
justify that well because that is
downright offense you're an absolute
fascist right you you you're a
particular purpose
this is actually a joke
you're an embarrassed country or
industry you're an embarrassment for
unions I'm not here how can you not
justify yourself
and get paid thousands of points
I think you've dug your own grave yeah
well I think we'll move on thank you
very much for
joining us I don't think it has has it
thank you
thank you Steve next tonight should
employers have to give a proper
justification as to why workers are not
allowed to work from home that's the
call from a conservative MP should we
really be making it easier for people to
work from home when an economy is on its
knees we'll be debating all of that and
of course our reaction to that
extraordinary chat with Steve Headley
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and dry January quite enough to turn you
to drink and a fillet steak should we
actually take part in these things when
pubs butchers and Farmers need our
support in the cost of living crisis
we'll be debating that one shortly but
actually we've just got to take a
breather because that was quite a Punchy
start to the New Year in terms I mean
that's my first interview in the new
year and all Steve wanted to do was to
throw frankly libelous allegations at
the periverse yeah and he didn't really
want to discuss the essence the
substance of the issue which is how do
we get through this issue with the rails
right well you had no original solution
so his whole thing was you're not
original you're just reading this I mean
obviously we weren't reading an
interview with him and then chucking out
this wild stuff offshore money Hitler
Youth mad fascist I mean just completely
Bonkers in all all my years of
interviewing people I have to say I have
never come across a character like him
and he was I actually found him quite
offensive he was offensive he was
libelous he was a full-blown communist
but the reality is he didn't want to
talk about the substance of productivity
improvements actually he was really on
the back foot when we talked about the
old working practices the Spanish
working practices and I got him when I
talked about the people who wouldn't do
the property maintenance at some
pancreas if they do Property Maintenance
at you they didn't have an answer he
didn't have the answer because he knew I
was right and he just didn't want to
discuss it and basically his whole thing
was just attacking us personally just
attacking us personally rather than
saying actually how do we help the
country quite extraordinary it seems to
me anyway there we are not a bad start
to uh Piers Morgan uncensored in 2023 so
moving on the chair of the commons women
and equalities committee Caroline notes
has called on employers to give a proper
justification for denying workers the
right to work from home
but as the economy is on its knees and
so many people are suffering mental
health issues I just wonder whether
working from home is really a Force for
good well despite coming out of lockdown
figures are clearly showing that civil
servants are still not back at their
desks three years ago there were some 27
000 desks being used in Whitehall and
now there's less than 22 000 that's a
reduction of about a fifth and across
the whole of the UK there's 1.8 million
square meters of workspace that's no
longer being used in The Civil Service
that's the size of about 250 football
pitches
so joining us now are broadcaster
Harriet Minter along with journalist
Angela Epstein and Harry you've written
quite extensively on this issue isn't it
this is your your main subject on uh the
kind of the the merits as it were of
working from home so I have been a
long-term fan of having more flexibility
in how and where we work so thinking
about actually how we move our working
practices into the 21st century we know
that nine to five Monday to Friday was
created by Henry Ford 100 years ago for
workers on a production line that's not
how the majority of us are working in
2023 so we need to think about actually
how do we work in a way that is really
efficient that enhances productivity and
that gives people actually a better
sense of their whole life and work as
part of it rather than trying to cram
everything into the hours outside well
it all sounds very nicey nicey but what
about productivity I think because
that's the key because we look at
productivity the reality is that
certainly in the public sector I think
we're seeing some serious productivity
issues and I think this is a good moment
to bring in the journalist Angela
Epstein Angela a very good evening to
you thanks for being with us so what's
your view on this Harriet is is
convinced that working from home makes
people more productive I need a bit more
convincing than that what's your view
Angela well let me just put a little bit
of skin in the game here
um I my second son is now 27 years old
clearly I was a child bride
um but um but I started working from
home when I went freelance I gave up a
staff job after he was born and it made
me thoroughly miserable but I battled on
and did it through for years through
another two children I think it made me
a bad a bad mother because I was always
definitely I think it made I was very
frustrated because I was thinking but
funny I could just put on a suit get out
finish the job at work come home and not
have the work hanging over me all the
time because it's ever present and
obviously the work of a journalist is to
that degree that kind of work I mean I
wasn't a news reporter on the front line
I was I was writing features but you
know you're not within the confines of
an office and I felt I lost a bit of my
soul in the process I felt guilty when
the kids came in from school and I was
halfway through something I felt guilty
if I I mean I always met a deadline but
sometimes it nearly killed me doing so
um and now I've reached a happy balance
where I work not I don't work at home
home is my base but I also go into
offices to do some of my work I travel
for work and it's taken me a long time
to get that balance too but I think
there's so much that people lose out on
when they work from home the social
skill I mean we've talked about the
economy obviously in the footfall for
businesses that lives out from all the
traffic of people using their facilities
but I think as individuals I mean I
would hate it if my children my next
turn the Next Generation in their 20s
and whatever and work from home I think
you miss out on the social skills that
the productivity the Ingenuity the
imagination right sparking offering
ideas all of those things yeah well
Andrew I was so interested in what you
said there about working from home
making you a bad mother I mean that's
quite a divisive thing to say I have to
say as a as a mother of three I
understand why you're saying that I mean
children especially when they're little
they seem to have a kind of magnet
whenever you're on that laptop they come
right to you don't they and make your
working life as difficult as it can and
you end up feeling that you're actually
giving not giving your best to either is
that what you meant by that I I think so
I mean when I when I say a bad mother
you know I said them and I love the very
bones of them and and was there you know
picking up from the school Gates and
doing all of those things but I think on
reflection and hindsight is a wonderful
thing
um I hated the fact that a part of me
was always sort of lurching Elsewhere
yeah and envy is a horrible thing but I
I would look at friends who had kind of
um can I say ring fence jobs yeah a
friend who would be a dentist or was was
working in admin and there were specific
hours and they gave their all and yes
they had to negotiate with au Pairs and
nannies and and play groups and things
but once they were in there they became
the person they were and when they came
home they could then be mother again
um and I think that makes it difficult
absolutely wincing here I think you want
to come in
but but I do want to push this point
about productivity because it's so
important whether you're in the private
sector or the public access and I'm so
glad you raised it so what we know is
that in the first two quarters of 2020
which is the last point of data we have
for productivity productivity was higher
than when it was pre-pandemic so when we
looked at productivity in 2019 2022 and
we had more people working from home
when we had more hybrid working
productivity is high what's your source
of that because anecdotally
it's the national statistics yeah I
noticed that you've not commented on the
the parenting thing yeah so can I just
you have children I do not have children
I have lots and lots of friends with
children
to do your job we're not children
running around the house every single
woman I know who is a mother has told me
that at some point they feel that they
are a bad mother because they are
working oh it goes with the territory
generally right that's part of it so as
far I mean when people say to me oh if
you're working from home you feel like a
bad I have to laugh because I'm like
what do you want us all to do to stop
women working all together and just send
them back to be Housewives is that what
we should be saying but I'm interested
in this ons point because anecdotally if
you just look at what's going on in the
public sector I think many people would
feel that productivity that's why we
have data Richard versus anecdotes yeah
they're not scientifically so let's pick
up the home office right but so you've
got the home office where there's about
62 in December were in the office yeah
we've got a situation where the
homosexual admitted that the caseworkers
on the illegal migrants cost Channel
they're doing one case a week quite
possibly working from home you've got
DWP so we'll separate this out so we've
got caseworkers doing casework doing one
case a week
I don't know the two are connected and
that's why we look for the deities or
we'd question it where we don't say oh
they're working from home therefore
they're not doing the work but let's
take part then say why is it they're
only doing one piece a week why is it so
complicated why is it so hard well maybe
we let's look at passports for example
and we know that actually getting a new
a renewal of a passport became
increasingly difficult over the last 12
months when the passport office were
working from home productive or did it
become difficult because they don't have
the technology and the system set up to
do it properly now that's a different
thing if we're saying that actually our
government is not set up for work in the
21st century oh so you're agree with
that the public sorry has less
productive no I'm not I'm saying if that
was the case then please do show me the
data not the anecdotes but if that was
the case we have to look actually not
just at the people but at the technology
and the systems that are in place the
passport data was clearly irrefutable
everybody could see that Angela Jordan
just uh pop in here on this critical
issue as a business person myself I'm
very focused on productivity and I just
think it's collapsing in the public
sector where there's a lack of
accountability
absolutely and and you know we've got an
energy crisis and we're we're Heating
and we're lighting all these buildings
and nobody's there they're all at home
on their on their computers eating
hobnobs and all that kind of stuff I
mean I'm not not suggesting that work
from home are Slackers and they're not
doing their Bits And there are plenty of
people that I know work very hard and
there is scope for flexible working I
mean it would have helped as a you know
I would have definitely gone back to a
staff job if they've been flexibility in
terms of being able well things have got
some work from here we'll finish earlier
carry on in the evening I think a lot of
of women not just women with children
you know I don't want to sort of you
know Prejudice so this there might be
people with other domestic commitments
uh elderly parents somebody in firm
within the family who would appreciate
that flexibility but I think what we
miss out on here productivity is is a is
a response to our Humanity we're human
beings when we work well we work we work
with other we do more we produce indeed
cannot work we do it we do our work
better indeed
thank you so much uh Angela and thank
you very much thank you harriers I mean
maybe there's a there's a sort of a
hybrid where we could all agree that
actually maybe if you're sort of reading
or some boring dull report you might
best do that at home or writing a report
there's a sort of hybrid maybe three
three and a half days in the office and
a day two days a week working from home
I mean the kind of the flip side of this
and I think the hybrid thing is quite
attractive is if people begin to feel
Under Pressure that they should be able
to work from home and I do think that
Angela made a really important point
there about parents look it's really
hard to work from home when your
children are little you do end up
feeling like everything's just an
absolute mountain to climb you're
parenting poorly you're not working
properly because you can't concentrate
and it would be pretty bad if it got to
a point where we fetishize working from
home so much that actually parents of
young children are feeling forced into
that stuff and then you get more
stressed and under more pressure
actually from from your employers from
your bosses and we're full scale back
into the mental health scene back into
the whole Mountain
great well there we are fascinating
discussion we'll be talking more about
working from home for sure coming up
things seem to be working pretty well
when the military run the logistics
although you wouldn't believe it if
Steve Headley was in charge uh passport
control that was working well building
the Nightingale hospitals the vaccine
rollout the Queen's extraordinary
funeral arrangements to name just a few
so is it time for the military to solve
the management crisis in the NHS we'll
debate all that coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
well still to come tonight the fun
police are encouraging us to take part
in Virginia and dry January after over
indulging over Christmas well I don't
think I did maybe use it
um is it really what we should be doing
when so many businesses are struggling
so we'll be discussing that shortly but
first of course it's a new year but
reports of a crisis in the NHS are sadly
nothing new health secretary Steve
Barkley has been blaming High cases of
flu covered and fears over strep a for
what he's called the massive pressure
the NHS is facing over this period
but isn't this all just feeling a bit
like Groundhog Day I mean every year in
the country the media spent the whole of
January reporting about a crisis across
the NHS our hospitals and always lay the
blame at the feet of the government and
a lack of funding so the question is is
it time we bring in the Army to help
with Logistics and help get things back
on track well joining us to discuss this
is former chairman of the British
Medical Association John nagpul along
with British Army Commander down the
line Colonel Richard Kemp and a very
good afternoon evening to you John
um so uh yet again we've got a winter
crisis this feels as bad as ever but
every winter we hear it's as bad as ever
and the NHS has never had more money so
so what's going wrong it I just wonder
whether actually it's you've got the
doctors and the nurses and the
Consultants to try to do a brilliant job
on the front line but are constantly let
down in the back office by the
management
look um we've as you said been in crisis
for a long time in fact I remember
before the pandemic hit us in back
December January 2020 I I was doing
interviews about the crisis then if you
remember there was also the Red Cross
were drafted in so we've actually had
many years of the NHS trying to provide
a service without the infrastructure of
doctors nurses beds Community facilities
that we have actually needed but what's
different this time is the scale and
magnitude of what is an incredible
pressure with a backlog of seven million
patients waiting for treatment and
there's also another hidden backlog
which we don't talk about I'm a GP and
it's a backlog of suffering it's about
people who don't come into the
statistics of needing an operation but
uh children waiting a year for a mental
health assessment people with diabetes
it's rheumatoid who are waiting a year
to see a specialist and the suffering is
is horrific but we know waiting lists
are they're record highs yes spending is
it a record high so you've got to say
look it's not working under the current
system something needs to give something
needs to be reformed where can we bring
in extra help
urgently it's not just a question of
taking years to train the staff so I
want to bring in Colonel Richard Kemp uh
former Army British Army Commander
Richard a very good evening thanks for
joining us look we've seen in in other
walks of life uh the the military be
superb at organizing things Logistics we
know in the NHS for example one of the
crisis we constantly hear in China may
have a hopefully agree on this is that
too many people are sort of blocking
beds and not getting through the system
could the Army play a useful role in the
logistics of getting a flow through
faster of patients into a e through a e
into the hospitals and and back out
preferably to home
we might as well the Army's sorting
everything else out for the country at
the present so let's bring them into
this you might as well uh to be honest I
I think you know the Armed Forces exist
to defend this country but they also
have a core role of standing in or
providing support for the civilian
authorities when the government deems
that's necessary and if it does deem
that's necessary now then let them do it
I'm sure they can bring a lot to the
party that during the covert crisis they
played a major role in helping the NHS
to plan and organize a pandemic that
they hadn't faced before
uh and and that was a you know that was
an important function so they could do
that now they could certainly do that
now it's not the answer I mean the
answer is for the NHS to sort itself out
or to be sorted out some other health
and the armed forces are not they don't
exist just to put sticking plasters on
government to other government
departments that don't work properly I
want to bring charm back in here because
you referred to the huge backlog which
was linked to the response to the
pandemic
um I mean the BMA had to play its part
in that though didn't it you say you're
a GP uh one of the reasons there is such
a backlog is because there was not good
access to GP Services during the
pandemic your members are responsible
for that partly are they not no I I
wouldn't say that at all in fact uh we
and myself as a GP followed in fact the
instructions the directives of NHS
England it was NHS England who actually
told us that we should not be spreading
the infection in our waiting rooms
couldn't you you could have pushed back
and you chose instead to repeatedly
endorse the whole online appointments
which of course works for some people
but was pretty catastrophic for others
but you know the the ultimate issue we
have in the NHS isn't about what may or
may not have occurred during the covet
pandemic although that of course has
made things much worse but what we've
seen over successive years before the
pandemic is a downgrading of our
infrastructure and you know when you
just look at the facts we have about 45
000 fewer doctors compared to oecd
averages Germany has three times as many
four times as many hospital beds per
capita France three times as many so so
in fact we don't know capacity yeah but
I'm going to pick you up on there
because actually the oecd spending the
UK is almost bang in the middle of
average spending per capita which is the
right measurement to use so that seems
to prove that you're right the data
clearly shows there's not enough doctors
per thousands nor nurses nor beds so
therefore where's the money going and my
concern is the money is going to ever
more layers of bureaucracy bloated
management that's actually blocking
things and that's why I think it may be
useful to bring in another pair of eyes
to help out we'll want this great public
service to work smoother faster and with
better outcomes look we all want the NHS
and I want the NHS to be as efficient as
possible but I think that when you look
at current spending which includes the
spending on during the covert period
including the 37 billion spent on tests
and Trace that's not the same as what
has occurred in the last 10 years where
the UK has spent according to the
nuffield trust about 30 billion pounds
less than our EU neighbors do you think
that 37 billion on test and Trace was
money well spent no I don't I really
don't
um I I I I I I we I mean I don't need to
rehearse all the arguments it really was
a huge sum of money that did not achieve
what it should have done okay and to ask
a really difficult question is the NHS
as it currently is is it fit for purpose
I think um and I I actually really
believe that the NHS if it was given the
right infrastructure would be fit for
purpose I'll tell you why that's not
what I asked so I ask is is it fit for
purpose now at the moment it's certainly
not delivering on the on the
population's needs but I'm very it's not
fit for purpose no I didn't say that it
is fit for purpose as a system and I
remember I've been a GP for 30 years and
I remember when I was telling patients
that the standard for them was to
actually wait 18 months for a hip
operation that was the that was the
standard of the NHS
I saw the investment during
um it was actually Tony Blair's term and
it went down to 18 weeks yeah so what it
proves is that give us the right
resources we can deliver one of the
reasons for that actually and you're
quite right about that is that they use
the private healthcare sector much much
more than is currently the case just
before we finish I just want to go back
to Colonel Kemp because
um this issue of uh you know Charmed
accepts that things are not working as
they should just what sort of capacity
might there be within Logistics or
engineers
for how many months to try and to try
and help solve some of the blockages
that feels to me such a critical
short-term issue
well I think the Armed Forces helped
during covid and one of the major it
wasn't just Manpower it wasn't just
providing people to do Jabs or to take
tests but one of the major issues was
organization the Armed Forces know how
to organize in the event of a crisis and
that's what they use they use those
skills and that helps I think the NHS
enormously in addition to that there is
of course medically trained Personnel in
the forces there are doctors nurses
other Specialists who could be deployed
but on a relatively limited scale
because the Army has been cut or the
armed forces have been cut to such a
degree there's actually very few of them
now compared to what what perhaps once
there was so they could provide an
impact they could provide help but I
think mainly they you know if if I was
to guess what assistance they would
provide it would be in terms of
organization planning leadership as well
and I think leadership is in many ways
is a fundamental issue here the Armed
Forces is is pretty good at leadership
obviously there's a lot to be desired in
some respects but I think one thing that
seems to me to stand out about AHS is a
lack of leadership you've got too many
people who are being paid too much money
to be directors of diversity or of lived
experience and not enough people
actually don't get it started on the
directors of limited experience Richard
thank you so much for your thoughts
without question and uh John thank you
so much indeed I think that's the point
though okay what Colonel Kemp says about
leadership and looking at it from afar
and coming in and saying right you
should do this and this and that that's
real leadership I also just think we've
got to be much more honest about the
state of this thing I mean how long do
we go on saying it's on it's on the
brink of collapse and all of that it is
broken and the question now is do we
actually have to have a fundamental we
think about what the NHS does well I
think we absolutely do I think we've got
to fundamental reform we all want the
NHS to be brilliant but the truth is at
the moment sadly it's not well next
tonight yes Prince Harry we've got to
talk about him he says he wants to be
part of his beloved family not an
institution but is there any way back
for him after this latest explosive
interview and even more Bombshells on
the way in his latest his new memoirs
there we'll be discussing that up next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back well like most people rich
and I spent the last few weeks stuffing
ourselves with turkey and drinking a
little too much Foods well actually I'm
not sure I did I was quite careful not
so sure about you I'm a bit worried
about my skills you went on the scales
and then claimed they were broken
exactly well you know I've got to find
some excuse I have to say I have a top
tip for that have you ever tried moving
your scales around the bathroom because
you can get different results like if
you move them different places I got
about five different results I'm going
with the lowest one and of course at the
start of January always comes with a fun
police telling us all that we should be
not drinking and going for some veganery
scenario I am really so sure about it
I'm not sure at all I mean we've got
landlords Farmers facing the strain the
cost of living crisis biting is it
really time do we just look after a
health or maybe we should look after the
pubs and The Butchers instead well
joining us now is broadcaster former
brexit party MEP Alex Phillips and the
talk TV commentator Paula Rohn Adrian
great to have you with us
but look what treats we've got you know
we know how to give everyone a good time
the smell no I'm for it really sure what
even is it perhaps Alex you can explain
to us what's actually saving the world
and it's saving the world and it's
saving yourself
none of that is going to save me I mean
seriously well so these look okay so
these are sausage rolls with no
presumably no pork
um I have no idea what that kind of
pasty thing is that's going okay I'm
gonna be bullish I'm very bullish I'm
going in I'm going in you keep talking
folks well this is vegan cheese we're
literally seeing the lifeblood come back
into you no I think that's what's
happening live on it does it look like
the blood is rising in my face it's
plastic I am seeking volunteers for this
pink thing matching my shirt I don't
know what it's made of yeah it was just
a load of sort of processed cow parts
now I know that it's made of mold and
fungus in a vat in a factory I'm not so
interesting it's vegan ham actually just
to correct you on that it's vegan ham
um I haven't looked up how they make
vegan food though it is genuinely molds
and fungus and all sorts of reasons oh
now you tell me
it's also about sustainability though on
a serious note it's about sustainability
it's about us trying to find new ways in
which we're going to keep the planet
alive and ourselves yes because we're
not going to starve to death thanks to
climate change Etc we're not going to be
seeing masses of refugees coming across
the channel because we've got crickets
now that we can eat we've got ants we
can eat it's not sustainable with a
wonderful wonderful beef herd of
Aberdeen Angus creating delicious meat
when they're grass trying to set herself
up for something here because she
started talking about insects and things
so next time I have to say we will have
a plate full of insects
Alex you and I we can do it I went to
one of those restaurants you're the
first particular I actually rarely I
agree with you on some of this I'm not
so keen on the whole vegan thing but
definitely we should be eating less meat
and I don't think that's gonna but the
thing is about this vegan Trend that
people don't understand and also you
know what do you think Powers those
factories happiness and joy and Goodwill
for the environment of course it doesn't
the thing is that and stuff like that
gives you wind I'm sure
exactly then give me plenty of wind
later on I think it's about these
friends look these Health fads big food
the big food industry jumps on them they
did it with low fat they're doing it
veganism they try and make you feel like
you're going to be healthier it's going
to be better for the world it's just a
way for them to sell more Ultra
processed rubbish make a profit it
doesn't make people hell of here it
doesn't move the needle on climate
change at all it's a con but we know
that type 2 diabetes is one of the
biggest Killers now that we're
confronting with it in Europe
and that we're going to move on because
because we've got you know another huge
issue once again
more hot air from Prince Harry and he
has got an interview coming up this
weekend uh with Tom bradby who is a
former Royals correspondent knows the
Royals very well and I think it's
looking pretty spicy I wonder if we've
got a clip of that that we can show here
and every single time I try to do it
privately there have been briefings and
leakings and planting of stories against
me and my wife
you know the family motto is never
complained never explain but it's just a
motto
ah that wasn't Tom Bradley was it in any
case
um I think that the uh Bradley interview
is going to be pretty Punchy and yes get
more whinging from Harry now Paula
you're inclined to be sympathetic aren't
you tell us why well I just want to just
focus on that word that you use the
adjective of describing what we're going
to be hearing on Sunday evening you said
whinging and and Isabel I know you're
not talking about another human being
whinging about racism and I know that
you're not talking about another human
being I am talking whinging about mental
health religion about their loved one
wanting to commit suicide we heard her
own mother saying that so heartfelt so
emotionally so we're not talking about
we don't need any more of that though do
we really well clearly we do because
clearly people are not listening and
what we're getting is just this kind of
brick wall effect and when we get the
brick wall effect what that means is is
that the person who is hurting is going
to keep on talking but why why would you
talk so openly to the whole world if
you've got if you want to resolve
matters with your family if you want to
resolve your your mental health issues
surely do that privately you know with
your loved ones with your family Alex
surely that's the right what I don't get
is you know he's talking about how the
media gave him a hard time all the
intrusion into his life how it's caused
him so much distress how it's caused his
wife so much distress or the backlash
against her and what they're doing is
just courting more of that it's a bit
like giving an arsonist a lighter if I
was their therapist I'd be like I maybe
don't do the big Global six Series
Netflix thing you know listening he's
answered that question he said to us
down that camera he said to us every
time I wanted to do it personally I then
read something about me I then saw a
report about me or my wife I tried to do
it personally do we hear that
he tried to do it personally or do we
just simply dismiss it and this is is
where we go back to your question
Richard should we be doing this in
private should we be doing this
personally it's about mental health let
me answer that question no when you are
talking about something so powerful
something that has changed your life
ripped you away from your family
don't you just speak about it openly
well look I I think we're not going to
agree on this order on this one I'm
afraid but we've only got it no
definitely not had enough of those just
one minute left and um we did want to
talk about Mars they are making a
horrible reappearance Alex I can hear in
your voice you have got a cold I've got
a cold he's recovering from God we would
frankly have spent the whole of the
Christmas in the New Year behind a mask
if we followed government advice Paula
you on for masks absolutely I've got a
text message from my I got a text
message from my GP this morning asking
me if I'm going to come in wear a mask
and I'm going to wear it because the NHS
are asking me to and that's our
responsibility
possibility our responsibility is to
follow the evidence and there's no
evidence globally whatsoever that
ordinary masks make any difference it
didn't help people in Germany it didn't
help us with the Omicron variant that
there's no scientific evidence Paula
that they make any difference at all
except to frighten people so why would
you do it well I tell you what frightens
me what frightens me is what's happening
in China at the moment what's right
well what's well they've had a lockdown
and everyone complained about that
they've lifted lockdown and look what's
happening and what's frightening for me
frightening me is what's currently
happening in the NHS we are being told
that the NHS cannot cope we are being
told 500 people a week 300 people we've
been told it's worse now than kovid was
Let's Help the NHS and if they say wear
a mask we wear a mask Alex I was gonna
say what frightens me is they've got
such limited capacity in my face your
Hydraulics as it is if I stick a mask on
myself you're gonna have to give me CPR
on the tape table I can barely breathe
right now I mean don't stick anything
more I think I need a mask from that
vegan stuff well that's it from us we're
going to be back tomorrow whatever
you're up to make sure it's on censored
good night
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign